Eric is with us in Richmond Virginia hi
Eric how are you I'm great
Dave how much self better than I deserve
what's up good D I'm a little bit
nervous on the phone call here but here
we go
my wife and I we we jumped in head first
into into your Total Money Makeover plan
back in July okay so far we've already
paid off you know our guys and that's at
the end of this month we'll have over 20
grand paid off in debt so far
why tag um yeah we're rolling we cashed
out our silly life policies now all
right silly whole life policy so that's
that's making a big dent but my question
is this is there too much risk or too
little benefit to transfer a large
balanced credit card I would say on an
18-month ther percent interest balance
transfer to a new credit card of my
current banks and I could potentially
save hundreds in interest if I was to
switch that over and we have a solid
plan to really have the how much how
much is the balance it's 23 thousands
okay and when will it be paid off I
figure we can have it paid off in the
next five to six months when I do my
math on it because we've got a whole we
got inter current interest rate on it is
what eight point nine okay and you'd get
go to zero correct and so you'd
effectively save five hundred bucks
is that about it yeah four percent it's
how it's not even a full year at eight
point nine so it's about four and four
percent of twenty thousand five hundred
bucks okay I was five hundred bucks it's
up to you I'll take five hundred bucks
if you send it to me and put it in my
pocket but but on the other hand five
hundred bucks doesn't solve your problem
and so I'd emotionally don't want you to
feel like you did much okay you kind of
cleaned out the nickels out of the out
of the back of the couch it's kind of
what you did mm-hmm
you know so it's okay to do that but the
problem is you know people do all these
balance transfers and stuff here's the
the Bible says out of the abundance of
the heart the mouth speaks here's what's
interesting when people do that
sometimes they tell me they go I paid
off my debt with my credit card balance
transfer
well to see what that you see what yeah
no no I know but you see what the
problem is the problem is they felt like
they did stock they got out of debt they
were not a debt they just move their
debt correct and so that really under
him that reveals the danger in this
discussion is no you're not doing much
if you want to do it it's 500 bucks it
won't hurt anything but what gets you
out of that is you continuing to stay
mad and focused and intentional that's
what gets you out of that this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a $500,000 in the
cop